[Musique]
ce sont des chants bouddhiste qui
réveille dharamsala ce matin
[Musique]
à l'entrée du temple du dalaï lama ils
sont plusieurs milliers de visiteurs à
se bousculer
parmi eux galton toupane
un petit bêta de 95 ans
le vieil homme ne manquerait pour rien
au monde cette prière collective pour
souhaiter longue vie au leader spirituel
des tibétains
[Musique]
qui alterne soupe elle est arrivé de
bonne heure pour se faire une place au
premier rang
il fait partie des plus anciens
disciples du dalaï lama c'est d'ailleurs
pour rester à ses côtés qu'il est venu
s'installer à dharamsala
quelques décennies plus tôt
[Musique]
je ne me souviens même plus de la
première fois où j'ai vu sa santé je le
vois très souvent
et si lui m'aperçois dans la foule il ne
manque pas de me reconnaître et vient me
bénir en personne
je prie pour sa santé
[Musique]
à
après plusieurs heures d'attenté le
dalaï lama arrive enfin
pour tous pelle l'émotion est toujours
la même
je suis heureux il m'a béni
son aura est intacte
à 83 ans le leader bouddhiste est l'une
des personnalités les plus populaires
dans le monde
notre culture tibétaine est très riche
quiconque l'a étudiée c'est à quel point
les tuniques et précieuse
elle se démarque des autres cultures en
particulier dans le monde deux journées
cela fait maintenant 60 ans que le dalaï
lama vit en inde
en 1959
il quitte un tibet envahi par les forces
chinoises
[Musique]
galtes en poupe elle se souvient de
cette période comme si c'était hier
le vieil homme est l'un des derniers
rebelles d'avoir pris les armes contre
l'ennemi chinois lors des soulèvements
populaires des années 50
ces bouts de jong et là c'est moi
ou comme c'était mon ami nous
appartenons au même groupe armé
puis il a été formé par la cia
en 1950 nous sommes en pleine guerre
froide et le rebelle tibétains trouve un
allié inespéré chez les américains
soucieux de contrer la chine communiste
de mao
au cours d'un entraînement spécial qui a
duré six mois
la fia nous a appris à manier les armes
et à maîtriser l'art de la guerre
les services secrets américains ils ont
aussi fourni des armes pour nous battre
parmi ses missions au tibet sécuriser
les frontières au sud du pays pour
faciliter le voyage en clandestin du
dalaï lama
le futur prix nobel de la paix n'a que
23 ans lorsqu'il arrive de l'autre côté
de l'himalaya
derrière lui il laisse un tibet saccagés
depuis son départ en exil le dalaï lama
n'a cessé de dénoncer le génocide
culturel et l'enfer subies par les
tibétains depuis sa fuite
je me suis enfui en inde parce que je ne
voulais pas rester sous le régime
communiste chinois
cette guérilla nous l'avons mis en place
pour défier les autorités
je n'ai aucun regret d'avoir participé à
la rébellion même si pour cela j'ai dû
tout sacrifié
[Musique]
lorsqu'il quitte le tibet à l'âge de 35
ans
schouppe elle ne sait pas qu'il ne
reverra jamais son pays natal ni sa
famille restée là bas
comme cet ancien combattant ils sont
aujourd'hui quinze mille tibétains avoir
trouvé refuge à dharamsala auprès de
leur chef spirituel
en soixante ans d'exil le dalaï lama est
resté le pilier de cette communauté
tibétaine aujourd'hui encore elle
s'appuie sur son leader pour se faire
entendre
mais depuis quelques années c'est la
question de sa succession qui
préoccupent la communauté tibétaine
le dalaï lama va bientôt fêter ses 84
ans de leur côté les autorités en exil
se disent confiantes
le dalaï lama est très clair à ce sujet
la lune tibétaine c'est bien celle du
peuple tibétain et non la sienne
en 2011 il a abandonné ses fonctions
politiques pour les léguer à des
représentants élus par le peuple du coup
même si le dalaï lama n'est plus là nous
sommes capables de poursuivre notre
combat politique
au fil des ans les revendications
politiques ont évolué aujourd'hui le
gouvernement en exil ne revendique plus
l'indépendance mais l'autonomie
politique de la région du tibet au sein
de la chine
pour mener à bien cette lutte les
autorités misent sur le système éducatif
à dharamsala beaucoup d'exilés ne sont
que des enfants qui ont traversé
l'himalaya à pied en voyageant
clandestins souvent effectués à l'aide
d'un passeur
l'aube sans n'avait que 5 ans lorsqu'il
a effectué ce voyage nous garderons son
anonymat afin d'éviter des représailles
contre ses parents restés au tibet
la nuit
je rêve souvent de ma maison au tibet
je veux retourner dans mon pays
pour revoir mes parents
une séparation douloureuse depuis 2012
le jeune garçon âgé de 13 ans vit dans
le pensionnat de sept écoles tibétaines
il fait partie de ces derniers arrivants
mon père et ma mère ils m'ont envoyé
pour que je puisse étudier notre culture
tibétaine
ça c'est un pendentif qui célèbre les 80
ans du des la main
il me protège et il m'aide à me sentir
en sécurité
après deux mois de vacances c'est
aujourd'hui la rentrée des classes pour
l'obs temps à ses camarades
[Musique]
je suis heureux de pouvoir démarrer
cette nouvelle année scolaire dans cette
atmosphère chaleureuse
n'oubliez pas que notre motivation
principale dans cette école c'est de se
concentrer sur l'apprentissage de la
langue et de la culture tibétaine
[Applaudissements]
les 1100 élèves réunis ce matin vont
découvrir le programme de cette nouvelle
année l'école a organisé pour eux des
cours qu'il n'aurait jamais pu recevoir
en chine
[Applaudissements]
bonjour maîtresse merci d'être venus
vous allez bien
[Applaudissements]
pour certains d'entre vous vos parents
vivent très loin et je sais que vous
n'avez pas pu partir en vacances dans
cette école ils sont plus d'une centaine
d'enseignants à prendre en charge ces
enfants qui se retrouvent parfois seul
en inde dès les premières classes les
élèves apprennent à valoriser leur
culture traditionnelle
tibétain à l'étranger n'ont pas
l'opportunité d'apprendre notre culture
et notre revue dada mais comme le
souligne sa sainteté le dalaï lama il
faut étudier la langue tibétaine et à
travers et le bouddhisme c'est un moyen
comme un autre dd notre pays de protéger
notre identité est d'aider notre cause
sur le long terme
moi je suis tibétains c'est important
pour moi d'apprendre ma langue
maternelle
comme ça je veux parler tibétain avec
mes parents
depuis sa création en 1960 ce cursus
scolaire unique en son genre connaît un
franc succès mais aujourd'hui de moins
en moins d'élèves viennent directement
du tibet la plupart sont originaires des
régions bouddhiste de l'inde et du népal
jusqu'en 2008 environ 700 800 enfants
venaient du tibet chaque année mais
maintenant en raison du durcissement de
la politique chinoise leur nombre a
baissé
au tibet les manifestations populaires
de 2008 ont renforcé les contrôles il y
a plus de militaires postés le long des
frontières tibétaine
celle que l'on surnommait le min tit b
se dépeuple à vue d'oeil - d'arrivée
mais aussi plus de départ à dharamsala
ils seraient une centaine à quitter la
ville tous les ans dans cet atelier de
temps qu'à un art traditionnel
bouddhiste ces apprentis on te fait le
choix de rester ils sont les derniers
gardiens d'un savoir faire qui se perd
repasse un coup de pinceau ici et aussi
sur les cheveux là
à 29 ans sean penn est le plus doué des
élèves de cette école cela fait
maintenant sept ans qu'ils se
perfectionnent dans l'art du temps cas
ils rêvent d'en faire son métier plus
tard
au début j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
l'art du tanka par passion du dessin
mais c'est vrai maintenant j'ai aussi
conscience de l'importance de préserver
notre héritage culturel
si c'est possible un jour
j'aimerais retourner au tibet pour
enseigner cet art aux jeunes tibétains
depuis 2011 plus de cent élèves se sont
inscrits dans cette école ils ne sont
plus que 24 aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est vrai que le nombre d'inscriptions
est en baisse c'est notre plus grand
souci aujourd'hui
pas seulement pour les peintres
traditionnels mais aussi pour les
religieux dans les monastères pour tous
ceux qui pratiquent la culture tibétaine
c'est un véritable défi pour nous de
perpétuer la culture de notre pays
c'est difficile parce qu'il n'y a plus
assez de monde pour représenter et
valoriser notre identité
en tant que peintre de temps cas c'est
ma responsabilité de garder ce savoir
faire envie
[Musique]
en inde les opportunités sont rares pour
les tibétains
ici ils n'ont pas le statut de réfugié
ils sont considérés comme des étrangers
difficile de bénéficier d'un prêt
bancaire pour ouvrir son propre commerce
ou de se déplacer librement pour les
jeunes tibétains comme sean penn
l'avenir est ailleurs
ce midi le jeune peintre va retrouver
ses amis dans un café du coin ils vivent
de petits boulots
nous autres exilés tibétains nous
n'avons pas beaucoup d'opportunités ici
nous sommes défavorisés sur le marché du
travail par rapport aux locaux
si je vais à l'étranger j'aurais envie
meilleur j'en suis convaincu j'ai envie
de partir d'ici
c'est un grand rêve pour les tibétains
de partir à l'étranger
le rêve de pouvoir construire une
carrière et de développer ses talents
[Musique]
à dharamsala la diaspora tibétaine se
pose plus que jamais la question de son
avenir
alors que pékin menace de choisir
lui-même le successeur du 14ème dalaï
lama et détendre un peu plus sa mainmise
sur le tibet les exilés garde l'espoir
de résoudre le conflit tibétains d'ici
les prochaines années et de permettre
ainsi à leur leader spirituel de revoir
son pays natal une dernière fois après
60 ans en exil